Welcome back to further explorations of the UCC section two seven Oh eight,
section two seven Oh eight subparagraph two doesn't only cover lost volume
sellers.
There are other circumstances in which the damages calculated according to two
seven Oh eight subparagraph one might be inadequate.
Let's consider a hypothetical.
Imagine a seller [inaudible] entered into a contract with a buyer Bisco whereby
smergo would manufacture and sell 200 toaster ovens to Bisco for our $60 per
oven,
uh,
for a total of $12,000.
Bisco repudiates the agreement while summer go is manufacturing the ovens
because the market for toaster ovens is dismal.
SMERGO stops,
uh,
manufacturing them.
Smergo suse and proves the following facts.
The market price for ovens if completed at the time and place of tender was
$7,000.
[inaudible] can sell them material.
He's amassed for manufacturing the ovens for $3,500 smirk.
We'll have $800 in cost of shipping the ovens to the buyer.
Uh,
if,
if the,
if the ovens were completed and sold a smirk,
GGO has incurred $6,000 in expenses at the time of the breach.
SMERGO would have to spend $600 more to perform the contract and smirk go has
allocated overhead at $10 per oven,
uh,
for a total of $2,000.
What would damages look like under two seven Oh eight one.
And what would they look like under subparagraph two seven Oh eight two uh,
plugging in the data we have to the formula provided in those provisions,
we'd get the following that four to seven Oh eight one we'd have the $12,000
contract price minus the $7,000 market price plus $0 million for incidental
damages minus $800,
uh,
as the expenses saved for shipping,
which equals $4,200.
Note that this amount is not taking into account the amount smergo has incurred
in expenses is overhead or the value of manufacturing materials?
Well,
what would damage his be under two seven Oh eight subparagraph to one formula
offered by professor John Siebert for calculating damages under that provision.
In the case,
in cases that don't involve lost volume is as follows,
you take the unpaid contract price minus total variable costs plus incidental
damages plus reliance damages.
Minus the proceeds of resale minus expenses saved.
And here is how subparagraph to damages would look like.
They would be equal to $12,000 minus $6,600 plus zero plus $2,500 minus zero
minus $800 which all adds up to $7,100.
The first formula does not capture smirk goes expected profits,
including fixed cost nor his reliance damages.
The second formula does and would produce a greater damage.
So in this case,
Margot would want to argue that sub paragraph to damages were appropriate
because sub paragraph one would be insufficient to put them in as good a
position as if uh,
the buyer had performed.
Catch your breath.
And now let's consider another mathematical hypothetical.
Suppose a middleman agrees to supply 9,000 units of goods to a buyer in six
regular installments on July 1st and on January 2nd of every year for three
years at $100 per unit.
At the time of the first scheduled delivery,
which is July 1st,
the market price for the goods was $95 per unit.
At that time,
the seller delivered 1500 units.
But by December 1st the price plummeted to $45 per unit.
The buyer repudiated on that date.
At this point,
the seller had a forward contract with an option to purchase 1500 units for the
next installment at $75 per unit and had no other goods or forward contracts on
the date for the next delivery,
which is January 2nd by which time the market price had now dropped to $40 per
unit.
The buyer rejected the second installment and said he would take no more
deliveries.
The seller sued on July 1st the intended date of the third delivery.
The market price was now at $50 but was expected to gradually recover.
The seller wanted to use t two seven oh eight one as the basis of recovery.
The buyer believes this will overcompensate the seller.
Can you see why
well considered the goods at the second delivery date?
The contract price minus the market price.
That is the measure of damages.
Under sub paragraph one would be $60 per unit,
but because of the buyers option contract at $75 per unit,
the profit would have been only $25 per unit.
Some courts would limit sellers recovery here because with his option contract
he had hedge the risk of a declining market price.
But in the third delivery where there was no forward contract under two seven Oh
eight one the seller would be able to recover $50 per unit,
the hundred dollar contract price minus the $50 market price.
The remaining intended deliveries are initially appear more complex because we
do not know what the market price at the time and place of Tinder would be for
these future deliveries,
but a different UCC provision section two seven 23 one provides that in such
situations,
uh,
where the time for performance has not yet occurred.
The market price at the time the seller learned of the repudiation,
which here is $45 will be used to calculate damages for all these remaining
delivery times.
So the seller would get $55 per units for all of these final delivery times.
As these examples suggest,
the damage calculation rules can lead to very different and somewhat perverse
results for different installments.
We've packed a whole lot into these,
this two part video,
so let's summarize what we've learned.
First we use Locke v Wade to discuss lost volume sellers.
Then we introduced and discussed UCC provision two seven oh eight and the
differences between subsection one subsection two finally,
we applied these subsections to two different mathematical hypothetical's and
together we calculated damages under each.